oh
that's not the sound I want to hear
this is one of my big irritants with
with high-level Trump supporters they're
in there drinking it's a big carnival
they love being near the president they
love the fancy beautiful architecture
yeah and they just it's like a beauty
pageant or something like they feel like
they've arrived I've seen it I've been
around it
and there is just a delirium and the
same thing happened as rallies oh we're
Invincible oh we can't be stopped it was
just drove me crazy Alex Jones is
completely correct there is a delirium
in the room at these events like the one
at Mar-A-Lago on Tuesday the vibe at
Mar-A-Lago we were watching it for like
an hour before Trump spoke we could see
what was going on
it was like you were there for something
positive and I know some of them are
trying to spin it into the indictment is
good because it means Trump is going to
win it might help him in the primary I
don't think it helps them with even a
single new vote in the general election
if he makes it that far but there is
again we just talked about cult-like
it's cult-like